today we're going to talk about the do's
and don'ts of your first week in law
school and I know you're freaking out
that's okay don't worry about it because
none of this is going to be on the test
the first week of law school can seem
completely overwhelming just take a step
back and realize that it's all going to
be okay
everyone feels overwhelmed you're thrown
into a situation that you've never been
in before you're learning about subjects
oh you didn't know existed it's probably
going over your head you probably feel
stressed out you might be a little
freaked out that's okay everyone feels
that way but let's talk about all the
do's and don'ts of your first week of
law school everything you can do to
maximize your chances of success later
on and everything you can do to minimize
your stress in the present you should
understand that the way that law school
is taught is completely backwards you
learn the most antiquated arcane cases
early on in the semester and there is
very little chance that any of those
cases will be used on the final exam for
example if you are in property you might
learn about Pearson versus Post which is
the case where two men pursue two Fox
but one man killed it and carried it
away and it's a dispute about who had
possession of the Fox and the rule of
law is that mere pursuit of the animal
itself does not give you a right to the
ownership of the animal but guess what
there are almost no exams in the history
of property we're citing to Pearson vs.
post is a way to get points on the final
exam it's weird because strangely enough
pursuing animals is not something that
is often done in modern society and
therefore they both situations just
don't come up that much so don't worry
that every single class seems to start
with these antiquated cases that will
not be on your final exam and really
don't do much to further your
understanding of the substantive law so
don't feel bad if you feel completely
overwhelmed with the arcane law from the
court of Exchequer in England it's a way
to ease into the some
sure and it's not information that
you're going to be responsible for later
on the second thing to realize is that a
lot of the information that your school
is going to give you is bad for example
I know that it UVA
the professors give over an hour lecture
on case briefing how to highlight the
procedural posture of a case how to
separate out all the different parts of
a case that information is completely
useless case briefs are just a waste of
time and the information it comes from a
good place they want to give you some
idea of what you should be doing but it
really just Foster's busy work so don't
feel bad if the information that you're
given an orientation or the advice that
you got before law school is
contradictory or it seems like it's
creating more busy work than it seems
like the benefit that you're getting out
of it it's probably the case you're
going to get contradictory advice and
unless it's coming from us it's probably
bad advice so don't feel like you have
to do everything that you were told
before going into law school and don't
assume that just because your law school
tells you to do something you should be
doing it often it's the absolute
opposite of that case with respect to
case briefs I see professors giving the
advice that all students should case
brief every case that they get I think
that's really terrible advice in fact we
have an entire video on why case
briefing is bad and why you shouldn't do
it if you feel you must case brief do it
once and then put it aside I know the
final exam might seem like it's a long
way off but take a look at an issue
spotting exam and see if there is any
way that you can imagine that you can
use the information of a case brief in
the final exam odds are you can't and
I've been doing this for a while I've
never seen a case where using all of the
information in a case brief actually
helped on the final exam
I think it's just busywork it's a waste
of time next you're going to meet a lot
of people think about forming a study
group but don't put a lot of pressure on
yourself study groups can be great
they're not always necessary some people
learn better in groups some people will
feel like they waste a lot of time just
going on an endless conversation in
study groups feel it out perhaps start
up a study group but don't feel bad if
you don't want to join study groups
or if you feel like the study groups are
passing you by don't overcommit now is
the time to try things out I know it
feels like everything is coming down on
you and you're overwhelmed and slammed
but really you'll be able to separate
what's working for you and what's not in
the weeks to come in that vein
don't try to do everything know that
there's a limited amount of time that
you have and you'll want to really
maximize the things that give you high
return on investment things like
outlining things like practice exams
things like distilling and synthesizing
your notes with commercial supplements
but don't try and do absolutely
everything don't try to join every
extracurricular and don't join every
single intramural sports team there is
time for some of that stuff but don't
feel like you need to try everything out
at the end of your first week what I
would recommend is start outlining over
the weekend what I like to do during my
semester was use your weekends for
outlining distill all of your notes with
all of your supplementary material your
weekends are your time well during the
week you're going to class you're
preparing for class carve out your
weekends to start outlining and if you
outline every single week by the time
the study period rolls around and finals
you'll be studying from your outline
while everybody else is starting to put
together their outline now sure there's
value in putting your outline together
but there's far more value in getting
that out of the way so you can study
from it and start using practice tests
and remember even though it's week one
you want to think about the endgame it's
all about finals it's very rare the
class participation counts for anything
so remember to always focus on the
things that are going to provide value
at the final it's never too early to
make that realization and understand
that it's almost all about essays even
in classes that have some
multiple-choice questions the majority
of your points are going to come from
essays and in most first-year classes
almost all of the points come from issue
spotting long-form essays and now is a
good time to think about the strategies
that go towards better essay writing
because a lot of your points and a lot
of your final grade is going to be based
on an issue spotting exam because so
many professors use
choose spotting exams you can use the
same strategies in every class
regardless of the substantive law legal
offers an entire class on mastering
issue spotting exams and there are
others as well that are also very good
but it's never too soon to realize that
most of your grade is going to come from
issue spotting exams so the bottom line
is it's week one but don't freak out
you're going to have the entire rest of
the semester to get into your groove
everybody starts out in feeling like a
stranger in a foreign land very little
of what you're learning in your first
week is going to be on the test so you
can try different methodologies of
preparing for class and working on your
outline you can find what works for you
and then really get into your groove for
the rest of the semester
I know it can seem completely
overwhelming but that's okay it happens
to everyone
now is a great time to take a deep
breath realize that it's all going to be
okay and think about the habits that
will get you across the goal line at the
end of the semester if you like this
video please click like and subscribe
for more law school crushing tips and
also click below to download the free
checklist to help rush law school so
thanks thanks for stopping by
[Music]